herzlich willkommen zur folge 198 des
faz einspruch podcast der wöchentlichen
podcast faz für recht justiz und politik
heute am 16 februar
2022 mein name ist corinna budras ich
bin berlin korrespondent in der faz und
mit der weiß wie der ph lorenz ich bin
freie journalistin und juristin aus köln
ja wir stürzen uns gleich in die themen
hier und da ging einige ist diese woche
ja wir beginnen diese woche mit einem
echten justizskandal ich nehme dieses
wort ja wirklich übrigens auch nicht so
besonders gerne im mund aber die
strengen worte aus dem landgericht
osnabrück lassen da nur wenig
interpretationsspielraum es geht nämlich
um durchsuchungen die im vergangenen
jahr kurz vor der bundestagswahl im
bundesfinanzministerium und im
bundesjustizministerium durchgeführt
wurden und die vom landgericht osnabrück
mit ziemlich deutlichen worten
einkassiert wurden und das schauen wir
uns gleich mal an
und natürlich schauen wir uns an das
bundesverfassungsgericht dass die
verfassungsbeschwerde von jan böhmermann
in sachen schmähkritik ohne begründung
verworfen hat ja das war nämlich auch
noch eine echte staatsaffäre also
jedenfalls war das vor einigen jahren so
anlässlich der schmäh gedichts des
comedian zu ihren böhmermann und er auch
diese stadt affäre wurde jetzt ziemlich
sang- und klanglos vom
bundesverfassungsgericht beerdigt aber
dafür haben die karlsruher richter an
anderer stelle ziemlich deutliche worte
gefunden oder ja und zwar mal wieder in
einem verfahren das der spiegel bis nach
karlsruhe getrieben hat gibt es jetzt
sehr sehr deutliche worte und zwar sehr
sogar personifizierte worte des
bundesverfassungsgerichts an den presse
senat des olg hamburg das ist auch
relativ selten dass ein gericht so
deutlich gerügt wird ja und im
schwerpunkt der woche geht es diesmal um
die ukraine krise und die frage was das
völkerrecht eigentlich dazu sagt das
habe ich mal gesprochen mit der
völkerrechtlerin an peters vom
max-planck-institut und dann haben wir
natürlich ein corona blog wer könnte
ohne den corona blog klar kommen im
moment
wir haben im moment relativ viele
lockerungs diskussion lockerungs
diskussions orgien wie die heilige
kanzlerin gesagt hätte wir hatten aber
auch das bundesverfassungsgericht ist
mit einem sicheren gespür für timing in
der vergangenen woche mal kurz zur
einrichtung bezogenen impfpflicht
entschieden hat und wir haben noch ein
paar nachträge zum thema corona da gibt
es noch ein paar updates
und hörer post und hörer post und
natürlich ein wunderschönes gerechtes
urteil ja steigen jedoch gleich mal ein
[Musik]
und wir fangen an mit der razzia im
bundesjustizministerium im vergangenen
september ganz kurz vor der wahl du hast
du schon gesagt kuchen waren sie sehr
deutlich wurde vom landgericht osnabrück
das den durchsuchungsbeschluss
aufgehoben hat der dieser durchsuchung
zugrunde lag die durchsuchung hat
stattgefunden anfang september die
bundestagswahl war ende september und
das ganze ist nicht nur ein
justizskandal sondern auch politisch
extrem brisant denn sowohl das
durchsuchte bundesministerium der
finanzen das damals noch olaf scholz
unterstand als auch das
bundesjustizministerium wo damals
christine lambrecht die chefin war waren
natürlich zwei spd geführte ministerien
und es kam schon damals recht schnell
der verdacht auf ob denn eine
durchsuchung so wenige wochen vor der
bundestagswahl nicht möglicherweise
politisch motiviert sein könnte das
bundesjustizministerium wollte sich das
dann auch nicht gefallen lassen und hat
rechtsmittel eingelegt gegen die
durchsuchung das muss man in der tat
hier auch noch mal deutlich sagen ja
also beschwerde hatte nur das
bundesjustizministerium
eingelegt aber letztendlich so wie ich
die entscheidung lese zu dir wir gleich
kommen des landgerichts osnabrück kann
man gar nicht anders als das im grunde
genommen auf beide durchsuchungen zu
übertragen ja also hier wie gesagt ist
formell das vielleicht als kleine
disclaimer nur immer vom
bundesjustizministerium
gerede weil die eben die einzigen waren
die beschwerde eingelegt haben aber das
ganze hat natürlich für beide relevanz
vielleicht erst noch mal anfangen
corinna worum ging es denn damals
eigentlich denn es ging ja eigentlich
nicht darum dass tatsächlich jemanden im
bundesfinanzministerium oder im
bundesjustizministerium ernsthaft
kriminelles verhalten unterstellt wurden
absolut also das ist vielleicht auch
kern dessen was auch damals schon klar
war was vielleicht auch dafür gesorgt
hat dass das ganze jetzt nicht ganz so
hohe wellen geschlagen hat war natürlich
thema im bundestagswahlkampf war auch
thema in einem dieser tree elle wo da
immer wieder herumgestochert wurde es
war also sehr unangenehm insbesondere
für den damaligen spd spitzenkandidaten
und heutigen kanzler olaf scholz aber es
war immer klar das ist eigentlich nicht
um scholz persönlich geht oder auch
justizministerin
lamprecht sondern dass da immer nur
hinweise beweise gesucht werden sollten
um
leuten um strafvereitelung im amt
nachzugehen also da es war eben ein
verfahren das die staatsanwaltschaft
osnabrück
schon relativ lange führte und zwar ging
es um geldwäsche
verdachtsanzeigen die bei der
zentralstelle für finanz transaktions
untersuchungen der financial
intelligence unit aufgeschlagen waren
dazu muss man eben wissen dass es um
diese financial intelligence unit schon
ziemlich lange deutlichen ärger gab weil
es eben eine behörde ist die zum
bundesfinanzministerium gewechselt ist
so sie sollte eigentlich auch
schlagkräftiger werden im kampf gegen
geldwäsche als das was man bisher
gesehen hat tatsächlich ist aber jetzt
auch die von dieser schlagkraft noch
immer nicht viel zu sehen es laufen
massenweise hinweise da hat ein aufgeld
welche verdacht liegt auch daran dass
inzwischen hinz und kunst solche
meldungen machen muss ja also vor allen
dingen natürlich die banken aber auch
nur
juweliere autohäuser alle diese gruppen
sind inzwischen gehalten bei jeglichem
verdacht auf geldwäsche diese meldung zu
machen die laufen grundsätzlich immer
ihm bei dieser kölner behörde eben der
fau ein und überfordern da diese
ziemlich dünn
ausgestattete behörde ziemlich deswegen
bleiben auch immer wieder anzeigen
liegen ja das ist so ein bisschen das
grundsätzliche konstrukt und das
ärgernis mit dem sich
staatsanwaltschaften und auch die
polizei schon seit ziemlich lange herum
schlagen deswegen war es ja so
ungewöhnlich dass man dann tatsächlich
bis ganz nach oben gingen auch so
öffentlichkeitswirksam bis ganz nach
oben ging denn ein kleben aber jetzt gab
es ja schon den verdacht dass da was
also mal zumindest
mindestens fahrlässig verschleppt wurden
also der abend war der verdacht dass da
in der fau strafvereitlung im amt
stattgefunden haben könnte weil die
bestimmte geldwäsche anzeigen mich an
die ermittlungsbehörden weitergeleitet
hatten
das ist richtig und jetzt wollte man ja
gar nicht sehen ob tatsächlich herr
scholz daran einen unmittelbaren anteil
hatte sondern es ging eigentlich nur
darum wie die obersten behörden also
nahm durch das
bundesfinanzministerium aber auch im
zusammenspiel mit nimmt mit dem
bundesjustizministerium
da diese ganze geld welcher einheit
sozusagen betreut welche welche
anweisungen die den an die hand geben
wie mit solchen weiterleitungen
umzugehen dass also das war im grunde
genommen der kern der ermittlung die
sich eben dann auch auf das
bundesjustizministerium und des
bundesfinanzministeriums
erstreckten sodann gab es ja aber erst
mal zumindest eine telefonische anfrage
dann haben die staatsanwaltschaft
angerufen und ein sachbearbeiter im
bundesjustizministerium hat gesagt na ja
also ganz ehrlich jetzt geben wir
irgendwie nicht sachen hier einfach nur
raus weil ihr anruft
das wollen wir auch durchaus verstehen
kann es ist jetzt also grunde genommen
deswegen waren auch viele so viel kann
ich schon mal sagen im
bundesjustizministerium und
bundesfinanzministerium
fassungslos weil was eben passiert war
es mann hatte bei einer anderen
durchsuchung schreiben
schon beschlagnahmt
konkret ging es um ein schreiben des bmi
jva also des justizministeriums an das
bundesfinanzministerium für finanzen wo
es um die zusammenarbeit der
zentralstelle für finanz transaktions
untersuchungen mit den
strafverfolgungsbehörden geht ja und
dann rief eben eine staatsanwältin im
bundesjustizministerium an sagte wir
bräuchten noch das eine oder andere
dokument und die sagten also ganz
ehrlich hier telefonisch rücken egal ist
raus aber
kommt doch mit einer schriftlichen bitte
und wo er ziemlich genau beschreibt
welche dokumente ihr wollt und dann
rücken wir die schon drüber nach das
wird nicht der genaue wortlaut gewesen
sein aber ich glaube es war so ein
zusammenspiel zwischen deutlich zu
machen okay also auf dieser basis
aufgrund eines telefonanrufs können wir
jetzt leider nicht geben aber wenn sie
schriftlich mal anfragen dann wird das
sicherlich kein problem sein ja und sie
haben aber nicht schriftlich angefragt
dass es wohl relativ klar das hat auch
das landgericht osnabrück so deutlich
gemacht sondern sind dann eben am 9
september dar einmarschiert sehr zum
entsetzen der jeweiligen mitarbeiter
und das sorgte wie gesagt natürlich für
ärger mann hatte ziemlich deutlich
gesagt auch olaf scholz hat sich dann
sehr deutlich positioniert und gesagt
das war komplett übertrieben und
unverhältnismäßig und das landgericht
osnabrück
und zwar die zwölfte große strafkammer
hat ihm da durchaus recht gegeben ja
denn die haben sehr deutlich gesagt dass
grundsätzlich eben erst mal schriftlich
angefragt werden muss ja und das ist nur
dann entbehrlich wenn eine ablehnung
sicher zu erwarten ist eine vernichtung
von beweismitteln zu befüllen wäre oder
eine besondere dringlichkeit anzunehmen
wäre und all das sah die zwölfte große
strafkammer als nicht erfüllt an ja und
haben insbesondere gesagt ja auch die
bundestagswahl muss man ja mal sagen
dass selbst wenn die regierung wechselt
und das sei ja durchaus schon damals
danach aus kann man nicht unbedingt
davon ausgehen dass dann auf einmal
irgendwelche fakten materialien verloren
gehen ja also das wurde tatsächlich
offensichtlich als als grundlage für
diesen durchsuchungsbeschluss wirklich
angeführt so nach dem motto 'wenn hat
irgendwie dass das die führung im
ministerium wechselt dann geht das ganze
beweismaterial verloren hat das
landgericht gesagt ja netter versuch sie
haben ja sogar obendrauf auch noch
gesagt dass lagen nicht nur die die
voraussetzungen für eine durchsuchung
gar nicht vor sondern ich war auch noch
unverhältnismäßig also wieder war die
erforderlich noch war sie alle und sie
war nicht erforderlich um das man
deutlich zu sagen weil dieses
schriftstück was die haben wollten schon
vorlag ja also letztendlich die werden
jetzt noch viele andere sachen
beschlagnahmt haben sie vielleicht auch
interessant ist aber dass worum es denen
geht sagt jedenfalls das landgericht
osnabrück auch mit ziemlicher
deutlichkeit lag eigentlich schon vor
deswegen sei diese durchsuchung auch
schon gar nicht ihm erforderlich gewesen
und die frauen die ihn wirklich auch
rechts und links noch mal eine um die
ohren muss gesagt werden also sowohl
dass diese kritik richtet sich dann vor
allen dingen an die staatsanwaltschaft
osnabrück die allerdings ja aber auch um
das man deutlich zu sagen achtung tatort
fans die können natürlich erst dann
einen rücken wenn ein gericht den
beschluss erlassen hatten einen
durchsuchungsbeschluss erlassen hat das
macht natürlich nicht die
staatsanwaltschaft die vollzieht nur
dass der beschluss wird von dem
amtsgericht osnabrück in diesem fall
eben erlassen so jetzt sagt das
landgericht ganz deutlich wird
ungeachtet dessen gleichwohl eine
durchsuchung angeordnet und das bmj v
dem verdacht ausgesetzt sich nicht
rechtstreu zu verhalten ist dies
geeignet dem ansehen der bundesrepublik
deutschland und ihrer institution ein
nicht unbeachtlichen schaden zuzufügen
also das ist schon ziemlich deutlich in
einem in einer pressemitteilung
ja also das ist wirklich juristisch
schon echt eine ohrfeige aber es ist ja
auch vor allem politisch brisant denn
man muss als hintergrund eben wissen
dass der staatsanwalt der diesen
beschluss beantragt hat genauso wie die
richterin die den beschluss erlassen hat
beide mitglieder der cdu sind und die
justizministerin in niedersachsen dass
die publisher ist auch von der cdu und
so kann natürlich damals dieser vorwurf
auch sehr schnell auf dass das alles
politisch motiviert sei weil er eben
diese beiden ministerien spd geführt
waren hat das jetzt konsequenzen corinna
ich meine die spd ist nicht besonders im
just im moment oder nee also die wird
das natürlich weidlich auswalzen davon
kann man schon mal ausgehen die spd
chefin saskia esken ist schon
vorgeprescht und hat deutlich gesagt da
muss es konsequenzen geben
aus diesem urteil
es müsse geklärt werden wie weit die
damalige und jetzige cdu führung über
die vorgänge informiert waren dazu muss
man ja auch sagen dass die
staatsanwaltschaft grundsätzlich
dem
justizministerium unterstellt ist also
dem jeweiligen
landesjustizministerium das sorgt auch
immer wieder für einerseits ärger oder
auch kritik oder eben für auch im bösen
anschein wie in diesem konkreten fall
also ist alles nicht besonders gut
gelaufen schreibt auch nach aufklärung
nach einem untersuchungsausschuss für
möglich also die grünen in niedersachsen
haben glaube ich auch schon gesagt dass
sie die justizministerin auf jeden fall
befragen wollen also darüber ob das
ministerium vielleicht falsch informiert
worden ist wie das künftig verhindert
werden soll und so weiter also das
dürfte definitiv noch ein nachspiel
haben bislang hat sich wohl noch niemand
geäußert da kann man aber vielleicht nur
einmal die stellungnahme der
staatsanwaltschaft osnabrück in diesem
zusammenhang erwähnte hat sich nämlich
auch auf diesen beschluss des
landgerichts osnabrück geäußert was
wiederum auch sehr merkwürdig ist das
passiert eigentlich
aber offensichtlich war die watsch'n so
schmerzvoll dass man das nicht auf sich
sitzen lassen wollte
ja und hier haben die noch mal betont
dass die staatsanwaltschaft osnabrück
von einem möglichen beweismittel verlust
aus ging dies gilt insbesondere für
flüchtige beweismittel wie elektronische
mitteilungen und die staatsanwaltschaft
osnabrück verwahrt sich auch gegen den
vorwurf das landgericht durch die
durchsuchung dem gedankengut von
sogenannten reichs bürgern selbst
verwaltern querdenkern corona leugnen
und anderen gegnern der derzeitigen
staats und gesellschaftsordnung
vorschub geleistet zu haben ja also da
hat die staatsanwaltschaft sogar noch
mal einen drauf gelegt ja vielleicht ist
das jetzt einfach mal so stehen
das klingt nicht so als wäre man sich da
besonders einig aber
so weit erst mal an dieser stelle und
jetzt gehen wir weiter zu den nächsten
staatsaffäre
und das war jetzt wirklich eine
staatsaffäre ich glaube das ist sogar
bei wikipedia gelistet unter böhmermann
affäre was jetzt vom
bundesverfassungsgericht sehr schnell
und sehr abschlägig beschieden wurde wir
erinnern uns alle zumindest dunkel daran
dass jan böhmermann im jahr 2016 in
seiner zdf-show seine sogenannte
schmähkritik vorgetragen hatte und zwar
richtete die sich gegen den türkischen
präsidenten erdogan und das ganze zog
sich jetzt über jahre hin durch mehrere
instanzen jetzt hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht seine
verfassungsbeschwerde abgewiesen
vielleicht fangen wir erst noch mal an
und gehen nochmal zurück ins jahr 2016
was war da noch mal passiert worum ging
es denn eigentlich das war in der tat
eine sehr interessante gemengelage
schon die show von böhmermann war ja
eine reaktion auf den staatspräsidenten
erdogan weil dieser sich zuvor aufgeregt
hatte über ein satirisches lied in der
ndr sendung extra3
da hatte er den deutschen botschafter
einbestellt in istanbul und dem
ordentlich die leviten gelesen und da
auf diese gemengelage auf diese
situation hat über mann mit seinem
berühmten gedicht
antworten wollen so und was war die idee
dahinter dass man dem
türkischen staatspräsidenten mal zeigt
was sozusagen die grenzen sind von der
meinungsfreiheit in deutschland auch
dieser tiere freiheit und dem was dann
aber nicht zulässig ist und das wurde
eingebettet in dieser show zusammen mit
seinem sidekick hatte eben erst mal eine
kleine einführung gegeben in seinem
gedicht und hat deutlich gesagt das darf
man eigentlich gar nicht hier in
deutschland sagen und hat es dann
natürlich gerade deswegen doch gemacht
also das wunderschöne stil mit der
paralyse ja zu sagen also ich hier
wollen wir eigentlich gar nicht drüber
reden dürfen wir auch gar nicht mehr
aber machen es natürlich trotzdem so und
das hat es in der tat in sich also da
konnte man auch als unbedarfte zuschauer
durchaus schockiert sein denn es ging er
hat so ziemlich alles ausgepackt was man
auspacken kann also hat ihn persönlich
beleidigt auch über
intimes gesprochen ihm intime vorwürfe
gemacht über sexualpraktiken und all das
was man lieber nicht in eine öffentliche
show tun sollte und dass auch das muss
man deutlich sagen in weiten teilen
wirklich absolut überzogen war und auch
zwar so überzogen das eigentlich jedem
deutlich werden musste dass diese
sexualpraktiken frei erfunden waren und
dass es eben gerade nicht wahr was über
erdogan bekannt war jedem außer herrn
erdogan oft
der satire wurde schon ziemlich deutlich
bedient und das hatte natürlich
rechtliche konsequenzen und zwar
wirklich mannigfaltige rechtliche
konsequenzen wir hatten einiges an
strafrechtlichen vorwürfen auch was gab
es dafür eine wunderschöne strafanzeige
wegen präsidenten beleidigung die ist
damals auch zugelassen wurden und
gleichzeitig dachten sich dann alle ups
was ist das für eine hässliche
vorschrift die kein mensch mehr braucht
deswegen wurde diese vorschrift zum
ersten erst 2018 dann auch abgeschafft
davon hat wenn man aber noch nicht
profitiert sondern die
staatsanwaltschaft mainz hat tatsächlich
auch brav ermittlungen eingeleitet hat
dann aber die ermittlungen eingestellt
das sei ganz offensichtlich keine
beleidigung weil jeder bezug zu
tatsächlichen gegebenheiten
offensichtlich viele so also ich glaube
das war auch irgendeine entscheidung mit
der jeder gerechnet hatte weil
tatsächlich eben dieses gedicht so
absurd war das ist klar war dass nichts
davon einen einen ernsthaften tatsachen
vorwurf beinhaltete aber
wie gesagt es wurde immerhin erstmals
strafverfahren eingeleitet dann
allerdings eingestellt schlimmer war
dann der zivilrechtsstreit erfolgte und
der vor den gerichten in hamburg
ausgetragen wurde
erdogan hat das natürlich nicht auf sich
sitzen lassen und ist da auch
gerichtlich gegen vorgegangen wollte das
ganze schmäh gedicht ja verbieten lassen
das ist ihm nicht gelungen aber
herausgekommen ist wirklich ein ziemlich
abstruse
ja konstellation das landgericht hamburg
hat natürlich abgewogen zwischen der
meinungsfreiheit gemäß artikel 5 absatz
1 grundgesetz und die
persönlichkeitsrechten des türkischen
staatspräsidenten so wie es in solchen
systems wahrheit auf seiten von jan
böhmermann ja die meinungsfreiheit wobei
die kunstfreiheit haben so abgebügelt
haben gesagt das haben die bewusst offen
gelassen da es zu keiner anderen
entscheidungen geführt hätte deswegen
geht es eigentlich ganz oft immer nur um
die meinungsfreiheit was natürlich immer
man und co wahrscheinlich auch sehr
schade finden werden also insbesondere
auch unser filterung war natürlich ja
sie ja sehr enttäuscht darüber dass
jetzt auch zum thema kunstfreiheit nicht
viel gesagt wird ganz im gegenteil der
lang der richter am landgericht wurde
dann auch damit zitiert dass er
eigentlich die kunstfreiheit in diesem
fall auch nicht verwirklicht sieht weil
die
schöpfungshöhe fehlte also dieser ganze
streit wurde ausgeblendet aber
interessanterweise ist eben nicht das
passiert was herr böhme mann und sein
anwalt christian schertz immer sehr
gerne gehabt hätten nämlich dass das
gesamte gedicht in seiner gesamtheit
auch mit der ganzen
vorgeschichte auch mit dem zwischen
geplänkels wurde ja immer wieder auch
das gericht unterbrochen und einsortiert
auch strafrechtlich schon selbst
bewertet ja das wollten die sozusagen
nur als ganzes bewertet wissen das
gericht hat sich natürlich auch diesen
gesamten kontext angeschaut und das
natürlich nicht einfach im luftleeren
raum beurteilt aber was ist schon
gemacht hat ist wirklich für vers für
vers dadurch zu gehen und die
überwiegende anzahl nämlich 18 verse hat
es dann für rechtswidrig erklärt und
deswegen deutlich gemacht und oder die
verbreitung verboten und sechs verse
blieben dann noch übrig und dann war
natürlich auch das ganze witzlos ist das
gericht um das vielleicht noch mal dort
zu sagen hat unterschieden hier zwischen
den schweren herabsetzungen mit bezügen
zum intimen und sexuellen für die es in
der person und dem verhalten des klägers
keinerlei tatsächliche
anknüpfungspunkte gibt und sie dienten
auch tatsächlich allein dem angriff auf
die personale würde und sind deswegen
rechtswidrig das sind die 18 verse von
denen ich schon sprach die hier
selbstverständlich
nicht zitieren darf aber die anderen
verse kritisieren traf ängstliches
verhalten in satirischer weise und seien
daher hinzunehmen ja also so zeilen wie
kurden treten christen hauen sind zb
erlaubt geblieben weil da das olg hat
gesagt hat das ist quasi in einer
politische kritik die ist erlaubt aber
insgesamt wurde ja diese
herangehensweise des olg schon relativ
stark kritisiert weil nicht nur
künstlerinnen und künstler sondern auch
juristen gesagt haben naja kann das denn
tatsächlich sein dass man einfach so ein
quasi gesamtkunstwerk in
anführungszeichen also etwas jedenfalls
was jemand als satire also auch als
kunstwerk meint einfach so zerpflückt
also überhaupt in passagen auseinander
nehmen darf und nicht sagen muss
entweder oder es muss quasi in gesamt
kontext gesehen werden und deswegen
waren eigentlich alle total gespannt wie
das jetzt weitergeht vorm
bundesverfassungsgericht der bgh die
beschwerde nicht angenommen aber man ist
dann zusammen mit christian schertz vors
bundesverfassungsgericht gezogen und das
hat dann jetzt am freitag halt echt
kurzen prozess gemacht ja und da war die
enttäuschung dann noch größer nennen was
das bundesverfassungsgericht
gemacht hat ist erst mal alle anzulocken
also hat tatsächlich das offensichtlich
so ernst genommen
das
um stellungnahmen gebeten wurden also es
wurden gleich mehrere stellungnahmen
eingeholt und die sich dazu äußern
sollten wie das jetzt mit der
kunstfreiheit
so weiter ist und dann haben die kurzen
prozess gemacht und am donnerstag noch
eine kurze mitteilung
veröffentlicht und gesagt die zweite
kammer des ersten senats also es war
auch tatsächlich nur eine entscheidung
der kammer wir sagen von drei richtern
und nicht wie sonst üblich von allen
acht die verfassungsbeschwerde wird
nicht zur entscheidung angenommen weil
sie keine aussicht auf erfolg hat und
das ist dann auch schon alles eine seite
mehr gibt es dazu von karlsruhe nicht zu
sagen so und jetzt hat das natürlich
auch raum für spekulation
geöffnet weil viele gesagt hatten er
warum macht ihr denn überhaupt so ein
fass auf und fragt hier nach stellung
nahm wenn ihr das ohnehin absegnen oder
absegnen wollt so war es ja die haben
wir tatsächlich auch das olg hamburg
dass er die letzte inhaltliche
entscheidung getroffen hat damit
abgesegnet warum macht er das es gibt
tatsächlich keinerlei erklärung keine
offizielle erklärung dazu denn man weiß
es schlicht nicht es gibt ja auch keine
sondervoten in solchen konstellationen
und ich darf vielleicht mal meinen
kollegen patrick bahners zitieren der im
filter und sich dazu geäußert hat kenne
ja sicherlich auch viele hörerinnen und
hörer weil er auch schon öfter in dieser
sendung war und er hat ja jetzt
festgestellt also wir haben werde nur
das resultat dass sagt hatte das was
böhmermann da widerfahren ist ist in
ordnung ja und das gibt ja dazu könnte
es jetzt zwei gründe geben entweder ist
man der ansicht dass die hamburger
richter das gericht zu recht als kette
einzeln zu bewerten der
meinungsäußerungen behandelt haben ja
dann wäre das so wie übrigens das häufig
getan wird in äußeres rechtlichen
auseinandersetzung natürlich wird dann
immer jedes einzelne satz jeder einzelne
satz passt schon jedes einzelne wort
getrennt beurteilt und natürlich immer
im gesamtzusammenhang gesehen aber
durchaus auch für sich alleine stehen
bewertet und dann entweder verworfen
oder
bestätigt aber das hat man aber wenn man
die kunstfreiheit mit eingehen würde als
prüfungsmaßstab würde das halt schon
richtig eng also da müsste man
eigentlich das gesamtkunstwerk in
anführungszeichen an berücksichtigen
richtig so und also beinahe sagt eben
entweder die finde das in ordnung wie
das gegangen ist oder man folgt
böhmermann darin dass sein gedicht nur
als ganzes verboten werden könne und
gibt bei der abwägung zwischen
kunstfreiheit und persönlichkeitsschutz
dann aber der ire erdogans den
vortragenden das ist jetzt die vermutung
von patrick bahners
tja und das wäre natürlich dann auch
schon wieder
politisch extrem heikel gewesen wäre
dann hätte man im grunde genommen das
fass auch wieder aufgemacht von dem
wahrscheinlich alle froh sind dass es
auch wieder zu ist also es ist so ein
bisschen zweischneidiges schwert das war
ja eine unglaubliche
aufregung damals eine große politische
verwicklungen bis hin zu bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel die hat sich da auch sehr
frühzeitig positioniert hatte zugunsten
von erdogan gesagt hat das sei bewusst
verletzen damit wiederum hatte sie ja
böhmermann sehr vor den kopf gestoßen
als das war eine extreme das heißt sie
ja auch später bedauert na ja also ich
glaube ja auch später hat sie dann
gesagt dass das ein fehler gewesen aber
jedenfalls war das wirklich eine
staatsaffäre damals und da es ist jetzt
halt wirklich ein schon sehr sehr
unglückliches ende mal abgesagt da eben
auch politisch gesehen mal abgesehen von
der juristischen frage dass man das doch
gerne irgendwo die aus karlsruhe gekehrt
gesehen hätte wie man eigentlich mit so
etwas umgehen sollte und ob man das
tatsächlich so machen kann dass man 18
von 24 zeilen verbietet in der sache
kann man natürlich jetzt noch zum egmr
gehen das halte ich jetzt auch nicht für
ausgeschlossen seien quasi promi anwalt
christian schertz gilt da ja durchaus
als sehr sehr angriffslustig das könnte
ja durchaus noch versuchen und dann
brach aber natürlich in der vergangenen
woche schon auch eine sehr alte
diskussion sofort nämlich wieder los
irgendwie müsste das
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht
eigentlich auch solche ablehnenden
entscheidung begründen das wollen wir
jetzt hier wirklich nur ganz kurz
anreißen das ist echt schon klassiker
also seit 1993 muss das
bundesverfassungsgericht
nicht mehr begründen wenn es eine
verfassungsbeschwerde nicht zur
entscheidung annimmt und das sind halt
auch wirklich viele mindestens 77
prozent der zurückgewiesenen
verfassungsbeschwerden und anträge auf
einstweilige anordnung werden ohne
begründung abgelehnt tatsächlich dürfte
der anteil sogar noch höher liegen weil
so wie es jetzt im fall böhmermann
passiert ist wenn nämlich keine aussicht
auf erfolg drin steht dann ist das aus
sicht des bundesverfassungsgerichts
schon der begründung so nach dem motto
wir haben es uns ja angeschaut das ist
alles irgendwie seit jeher schon echt
umstritten weil ja eben auch gerade das
bundesverfassungsgericht so als
bürgergericht gilt und dann kann man
hatte ich schon sagen na ja was ist das
bitte für eine art irgendwie damit
seinen bürgern umzugehen wenn man sagt
wir nehmen das nicht zur entscheidung an
punkt gehweg
zuletzt wollte die afg das ändern lassen
das war ich glaube 218 oder 219 die hat
aber wirklich nicht den hauch irgendwie
von von zustimmung auf anderen parteien
dafür bekommen das argument ist immer
dass das bundesverfassungsgericht
überlastet ist da kommt eben echt viel
an und vor allem kommt ja auch sehr viel
mist anwalts war kein anwaltszwang gibt
das bundesverfassungsgericht würde
zusammenbrechen so zu sagen wenn sie das
alles begründen müssten und es wird auch
immer so ein bisschen gesagt naja andere
bundesgerichte können das ja auch so
machen also zum beispiel der bgh darf
revisionen strafrecht als offensichtlich
unbegründet verwerfen das berühmte oh
punkt um punkt ist auch ganz berüchtigt
ich finde immer das ist irgendwie ein
schwaches argument zu sagen das macht es
ist jetzt irgendwie besser weise an
anderen gerichten auch nicht gut ist und
noch das mit der begründung pflicht also
der der komplette verzicht darauf
überzeugt mich am ende auch nicht so
ganz muss man sagen denn es ist ja nicht
so dass die dass die sich das gar nicht
anschauen und das irgendwie ungefähr ein
papierkorb schmeißen sondern wir haben
es jetzt gerade in dem immer
mahnverfahren auch gesehen da werden zum
teil an wirklich stellungnahmen
eingefordert von verbänden von da sind
es leute beteiligt werden hunderte
seiten papier geschrieben und am ende
heißt dann irgendwie schön das ist halt
irgendwie merkwürdig man könnte sich
einfach dann hinsetzen und eine din a4
seite das schon dazu schreiben wenn man
sowieso schon geprüft hat aber gut ich
glaube es wird nicht passieren es würde
mich sehr wundern wenn sich da etwas
ändern würde selbst wenn es jan
böhmermann betrifft
dann haben wir das jetzt abgeschlossen
und jetzt kommen wir wieder zu anderen
klaren worten nicht wiederum das
bundesverfassungsgericht sehr wohl
damals mal was gesagt ja genau die
können sehr deutlich sein wenn sie
wollen in gleich zwei verfahren die wir
heute noch für euch haben das erste ist
das vorhin schon im intro angedeutete
verfahren das vom presse senat in
hamburg kommt und da ist das
bundesverfassungsgericht richtig böse
geworden er hat weil nämlich das bunte
das olg hamburg man muss wirklich sagen
schon wieder eine einstweilige verfügung
erlassen hat in diesem fall gegen den
spiegel ohne den spiegel zuvor anzuhören
und ihm gelegenheit zur stellungnahme zu
geben und das bundesverfassungsgericht
will daraus sogar jetzt schon
unmittelbare konsequenzen ziehen bei
diesen sachen geht es fast immer um
presse sachen hier ging es um ein um
eben spiegel online und die wurden in
anspruch genommen von einem
kreuzfahrtunternehmen spiegel online hat
die eu wie ein interview veröffentlicht
kritisches interview zum thema
kreuzfahrten ist ja derzeit ein hippes
thema und da wurde eben auch dieses
unternehmen event das passe die nicht
also haben die spiegel und eine
abmahnung geschickt mit
unterlassungserklärung und der spiegel
hat aber gesagt machen wir nicht wie
finden wir fühlen uns hier im recht so
so weit so normal aber dann ging es los
dann ist das kreuzfahrtunternehmen zu
gericht gezogen zum landgericht und hat
gesagt hier wir hätten gerne irgendwie
dass ihr den spiegel dem spiegel das
verbietet das landgericht hat gesagt
also so wie du deine anträge hier
formuliert hast und was du in der sache
haben willst gibt es nicht keine
aussicht auf erfolg daraufhin hat das
unternehmen seine anträge umgestellt
zwar hilfsanträge gestellt tralala das
landgericht auch im zweiten anlauf nun
immer noch nicht wir weisen einen antrag
zurück das unternehmen geht zum olg
hamburg und das olg sagt dann auch wir
würden nur einem ganz bestimmten antrag
stattgeben die haben den also quasi den
den richtig zu stellen den antrag mit
dem sie dann erfolg haben können quasi
rein diktiert also hat das unternehmen
ist für wirklich merkwürdig und das
unternehmen hat dann die anderen anträge
zurück genommen hat diesen einen antrag
stehen lassen dem hat das olg auch
stattgegeben und im einstweiligen
rechtsschutz dann bestimmte passagen
dieses spiegel interviews untersagt und
noch mal von dem ganzen tag haben dass
sich über wochen zog wusste der spiegel
nichts und da musste man vielleicht mal
ganz kurz einschieben wie das
presserechtlich eigentlich ist denn hier
erlebt natürlich die es sinn dass man in
hamburg klagt weil da der spiegel auch
sitzt ja so insofern ist das nicht ganz
unangenehm aber auf der anderen seite
ist es eben auch so dass der hauptgrund
warum man in hamburg klagt ist nämlich
impress rechts gibt den sogenannten
fliegenden gerichtsstand also da kann
man sich aussuchen für welches gericht
man zieht und das kann man so deutlich
sagen die presse kammern in hamburg
gegen als extrem
verlags kritisch bzw sehr freundlich
sehr getroffen
den betroffenen genau also wer immer
sich da ungerecht behandelt führt von
den medien von dem presse bekommt in
hamburg gehört nicht immer recht aber
doch deutlich öfter recht vielleicht als
in anderen konstellationen
jedenfalls ist das eine hoffnung heißt
geheimnis kann man sagen und auch diese
und auch diese konstellation spricht dir
sehr dafür dass man hier den betroffenen
unternehmen die sache sehr erleichtern
wollte
genau und da hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt auch
gesagt da ist das recht auf prozessuale
waffengleichheit nun ist ein sehr
schönes wort finde ich offenkundig
verletzt also es geht halt darum dass
man immer vor gericht das steht im
grundgesetz beide seiten anhören muss
das kennt man ja irgendwie auch selber
naja man muss immer beide seiten von der
geschichte kennen und wer schon mal so
eine akte gelesen hat der hat das
wahrscheinlich auch schon festgestellt
wenn man den schritt sitz des klägers
liest denkt man oh stimmt ja der muss
aber auf jeden fall recht kriegen dann
bleibt man weiter dann kommt der
schriftsatz ist beklagt man denkt ach
guck mal so war das na da muss ich ja
noch mal drüber nach und das ist
natürlich überhaupt nicht gegeben wenn
man quasi nur die klägerseite und den
vortrag der klägerseite vor sich liegen
hat im presse und äußerung recht kann
das ausnahmsweise mal anders sein weil
vor allem halt im einstweiligen
rechtsschutz da muss es oft sehr sehr
schnell gehen weil natürlich durch seine
presseberichterstattung massiv
persönlichkeitsrechte verletzt werden
können wenn man zum beispiel eine
verdachtsberichterstattung nicht
vernünftig macht wenn man menschen
vorverurteilt wenn man unwahres
berichtet oder so das verbreitet sich
rasend schnell das steht überall im netz
kennt jeder und in presse sachen ist es
eben auch oft so dass das gericht die
auffassung der gegenseite schon kennt
weil nämlich ja derjenige der sozusagen
möchte dass die presse etwas nicht mehr
behaupten darf der legt dann vor was
vorgerichtlich stattgefunden hat nämlich
eine abmahnung und in der regel
antwortet der verlag er dann auf die
abmahnung die rechtsabteilung des
verlags meldet sich dann und sagt ja
entweder du hast recht mit einer
abmahnung haben wir mist gebaut oder die
sagen halt nur aus folgenden gründen
halten wir an unserer berichterstattung
fest doppelpunkt und wenn das dann alles
dem gericht ordnungsgemäß vorgelegt wird
und wenn er auch nicht viel zeit
dazwischen vergeht und dazwischen nichts
passiert dann kann es in ausnahmefällen
mal sein dass in solchen presse sachen
wenn es dann wirklich super dringend ist
und betroffenenrechte sehr massiv
beschränkt wurden das dann direkt bei
einer einstweilige verfügung erlassen
werden kann ohne dass das medium
angehört wird in diesem fall war das
natürlich absolut nicht so eine
konstellation denn dem gericht sagt ja
gerade nicht alles vor sondern der
spiegel hatte sich geäußert zu dieser
allerersten abmahnung und dann haben die
ja wochenlang erst mit dem landgericht
und dann mit dem olg hin und her
diskutiert was man denn jetzt wohl
eigentlich kriegen würde als unternehmen
und dieses unternehmen konnte schön sich
dann den antrag so zurecht basteln bis
es dann echt sicher sein konnte dass das
gericht das auch mit geht sogar in der
zweiten instanz und der spiegel wusste
von gar nix weil sie die wussten nicht
dass da womöglich jetzt völlig andere
argumente auf dem tisch liegen das auch
vielleicht völlig andere forderungen
gestellt wurden denn wenn man seine
anträge um stellt dann heißt das ja in
der regel auch dass man ganz was anderes
haben will nun also vielleicht eben
nicht mehr machte macht das ganze
interview weg und stellt das richtig
sondern zum beispiel so was wie wir
möchten gerne eine stellungnahme dazu
eingefügt haben oder stell mal die
quelle dar das kann etwas völlig anderes
sein ist halt blöd wenn man das als
spiegel und wenig weiß und wie hat jetzt
das bundesverfassungsgericht reagiert ja
die haben gesagt irgendwie uns reicht
das jetzt hier das war halt offenkundig
eine verletzung des rechts auf gehör und
die werden jetzt sehr deutlich weil sie
sich praktisch in dem gesamten gesamten
beschluss selbst wiederholen denn ihr
schon im jahr 2018 und auch in dem
verfahren des spiegel hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt es gibt
keine einstweilige verfügung ohne
anhörung auch nicht wenn es schnell
gehen muss sondern nur in absoluten
ausnahmefällen
dasselbe hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht im jahr 2020
noch drei mal gesagt keine einstweilige
verfügung ohne anhörung und das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt halt
schon vier mal gesagt und jetzt sagen
die karlsruher richter sehr sehr
deutlich das reicht uns jetzt hier und
da kommen echt klasse sachen die
stellungnahme des presse senats des olg
hamburg machte deutlich ich zitiere das
bei diesem offenbar missverständnisse
hinsichtlich der anforderungen der
prozessualen waffengleichheit bestehen
heißt es da in dem beschluss wörtlich
und ein einseitiges geheimverfahren über
einen mehrwöchigen zeitraum in dem sich
gericht und antragsteller über
rechtsfragen austauschen ohne den
antragsgegner in irgendeiner form
einzubeziehen ist mit den verfahrens
grundsätzen des grundgesetzes
unvereinbar
hmm naja also schlimmer geht eigentlich
gar nicht und das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt dann am
ende tatsächlich noch wir weisen
explizit in presse senat des olg hamburg
darauf hin dass die gerichte an die
rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts gebunden also
das ist natürlich wirklich eigentlich
atemberaubend selbstverständlich dass
man sowas betonen muss ist natürlich
echt schon mit klatsche für das gericht
und ganz am ende das ist jetzt auch
tatsächlich sehr interessant für alle
medien die in hamburg verklagt werden
sagt das bundesverfassungsgericht auch
uns reicht als jetzt wenn der presse
senat des olg in hamburg noch mal gegen
den grundsatz der waffengleichheit
verstößt also noch mal irgendwelche
einstweiligen verfügung erlässt ohne
vorher das medium anzuhören dann wird
das bundesverfassungsgericht immer von
einem sogenannten feststellung interesse
ausgehen weil die nämlich quasi dann
davon ausgehen dass eine
wiederholungsgefahr besteht weil dieser
senat eine machen ist ja immer so macht
und damit hat man eine
verfassungsbeschwerde eigentlich quasi
schon gewonnen genau das ist die
konsequenz daraus also genau also das
heißt wir alle zukünftigen vor allem
natürlich medien aber das gilt auch im
bereich des des wettbewerbsrechts die in
hamburg verklagt werden und die dann
überhaupt keine möglichkeit bekommen
sich irgendwie zu äußern die haben vor
dem bundesverfassungsgericht praktisch
jetzt schon gewonnen ja ja das ist schon
echt ein knaller ja also das ist ja
jetzt auch eine woche von klaren worten
aus der justiz hat man sonst selten
in der tat genau
ja nach einem justizskandal und einer
echten staatsaffäre kümmern wir uns
jetzt um die große auch sehr
komplizierte weltpolitik die lage in der
ukraine
und vor allem drumherum ist er
inzwischen sehr bedrohlich und das
wollen wir auch hier im faz einspruch
podcast ma vertiefen da bietet es sich
an ein blick in das völkerrecht zu
werfen denn der ganze konflikt offenbart
inzwischen einen ganzen strauß an sehr
kniffligen völkerrechtlichen
fragestellungen und dazu habe ich mir
diesmal verstärkung vom max planck
institut für ausländisches öffentliches
recht und völkerrecht geholt und ich
begrüße jetzt sehr herzlich frau
professor rückte anne peters sie ist
direktorin am max-planck-institut und
gehört zum netzwerk max planck frau
peter sie haben vor kurzem im faz
einspruch magazin einen artikel
veröffentlicht unter dem sehr klaren
titel russland verletzt schon jetzt das
völkerrecht den verlinken wir natürlich
auch sehr gerne in unseren shorts aber
klären sie uns auf was meinten sie damit
konkret
in der charta der vereinten nationen ist
als ganz wichtiges und grundlegendes
prinzip unserer heutigen völkerrechts
ordnung das gewaltverbot festgeschrieben
und diese vorschrift verbietet nicht nur
den die anwendung militärischer gewalt
gegen andere staaten sondern auch schon
die androhung militärischer gewalt und
das verhalten von russlands erfüllt die
voraussetzungen einer solchen drohung
mit rechtswidriger anwendung
militärischer gewalt und das ist ja
schon das was wir jetzt gerade sehen
also 100000 soldaten vor der grenze der
ukraine es sozusagen
wink mit dem zaunpfahl und weit mehr als
dass das könnte eine drohung mit gewalt
sein verstehe ich sie richtig
ja und zwar deshalb weil die
in aussicht gestellte militärische
gewaltanwendung
ein überfall auf die ukraine wäre und
das wäre eine völkerrechts verletzung
eine verletzung des gewalt verbots eine
verletzung der territorialen integrität
der ukraine als ihrer gebiets
unversehrtheit und eine verletzung der
souveränität der ukraine die durch
nichts anderes von seiten russlands
gerechtfertigt wäre und wer da die
androhung zwar nicht ausdrücklich von
russland so ausgesprochen wurde ja so
putin hat nicht angekündigt er würde
jetzt morgen die ukraine überfallen aber
diese drohung ergibt sich aus dem
verhalten
das nennen wir konkludente oder
implizite drohung ist vorhanden die
ergibt sich aus den umständen und es ist
ja auch aus den umständen ersichtlich
dass russland damit auch etwas bezweckt
also die ukraine und vielleicht auch
andere staaten zu einem erwünschten
verhalten singen möchte mit dieser
militärisch
sie haben es eben gerade schon erwähnt
präsident putin kann das eigentlich gar
nicht rechtfertigen aber er könnte es ja
trotzdem versuchen das mutmaßen
jedenfalls viele gäbe es denn der
verschiedene möglichkeiten die
ansprechen könnte hier eben auch zum
beispiel über das recht auf
selbstverteidigung in artikel 51 der un
charta
ja das was sie ansprechen das
selbstverteidigungsrecht dass es
neben der autorisierung durch den
sicherheitsrat die wichtigste ausnahme
oder durchbrechung des gewalt verbots
ein staat darf militärische gewalt
anwenden wenn er selber mit einem
bewaffneten angriff überzogen wird die
voraussetzung wäre also dass das gegen
russland ein bewaffneter angriff im
gange ist oder konkret droht
das ist aber in keiner weise ersichtlich
doch das ist ja ein argument dass
präsident putin immer wieder anführt
nämlich dass die russische bevölkerung
in den entsprechenden gebieten auf der
ukraine
drangsaliert werden dass er da
einschreiten muss zu ihrem schutz ja
also es ist sogar hat putin zum beispiel
schon mal gemacht im jahr 2014 den
überfall auf die krim hatte er unter
anderem damit
versucht zu rechtfertigen dass
menschenrechtsverletzungen gegenüber
russischen einwohnern gegenüber
russischen staatsbürgern auf der krim
passieren würden also die eine frage ist
ob das faktisch jetzt richtig war die
andere frage ist ob so etwas dann
tatsächlich rechtlich eine
rechtfertigung für militärisches
eingreifen geben würde und da gibt es
tatsächlich ein kleines fenster also es
gibt diese konstellation dass ein staat
zur evakuierung seiner staatsangehörigen
im ausland militärisch punktuell
eingreifen da auf das hat zum beispiel
deutschland
auch gemacht
in syrien das sind aber so und
rechtfertigbar sind nur so blitzaktionen
wo
einfach das militär eingeflogen wird die
staatsangehörigen evakuiert werden und
dann wieder raus so war es dann auch in
syrien das war die sagt und pegasus die
hat auch dann zur verfassungsrechtlichen
fragen geführt wenn es all bedürftig ist
ob der bundestag der deutsche bundestag
dann wieder da informiert werden muss
das hat auch einen
bundesverfassungsgerichts beschluss dazu
angegeben wie ist denn die lage in den
volks republiken lohans internets gehört
sind ja pro-russische separatisten am
werk und es gibt schon seit jahren einen
offenen und auch gewalttätigen konflikt
beeinflusst dass die situation in
völkerrechtlicher sicht ja und zwar
deshalb weil glaube ich jetzt die
staatengemeinschaft aus dieser situation
gewisse leere
eine wiederholung vielleicht vermeiden
will
formal gesehen ist jedenfalls klar dass
diese gebiete weiterhin unter der
souveränität der ukraine stehen also aus
völkerrechtlicher sicht
ukrainisches gebiet sind wenn auch unter
völkerrechtswidriger große schar
militärischer besetzung wobei russland
ihr am anfang auch und auch jetzt noch
immer wieder leugnet das ist da
involviert es erinnern sich dass im jahr
2014 nur erstmal von grünen männchen die
rede war also russische soldaten ohne
hoheitszeichen wie spielt eigentlich
eine rolle dass präsident putin ja auch
immer wieder argumentiert ich werde hier
dadurch bedroht dass die nato sich immer
weiter richtung osten
ausdehnt ist das völkerrechtlich zu
bewerten also die nato ist eine
internationale organisation
als
hauptaufgabe hat die verteidigung gegen
militärische angriffe von außen
ist nach dem zweiten weltkrieg gegründet
worden und hat in den 1990 er jahren aus
einem gewissen aufgaben wandel
durchgemacht
das auch so genannte out of area
einsätze erlaubt werden und auch
reaktionen gegen neuartige bedrohungen
zb terrorismus aber im prinzip ist es
ein verteidigungsbündnis und der kennt
dieses verteidigungsbündnisses ist die
beistandspflicht wenn nach artikel 5
nato vertrag ein
mitglied der nato angegriffen wird von
einem nicht-mitglied zum beispiel
russland dann sind die anderen
mitglieder zum beistand verpflichtet
aber übrigens auch ohne mitgliedschaft
in der nato kann wo können natürlich
andere staaten freiwillig beistand
militärischen beistand leisten ja genau
da können wir auch gleich noch zu kommen
aber im grunde genommen geht es hier um
die simple tatsache dass immer mehr
länder in die nato aufgenommen werden
wollen dass sie das schutz suchen auch
gerade vor russland
da kann er nun nicht umgekehrt russland
kommen und ins feld führen dass du
irgendeine art von bedrohung
von der nato ausgeht weil die sich immer
mehr ausbreitet nur um das nochmal
klarzustellen so geht es nicht oder ja
eben schon festgehalten
dass
russland nur zur selbstverteidigung
berechtigt wird durch einen bewaffneten
angriff oder durch einen unmittelbar
bevorstehenden bewaffneten angriff und
die existenz der nato und auch die
ausdehnung der nato die eher ein
verteidigungsbündnis ist stellt keinen
solchen bewaffneten angriff da jetzt hat
russland
behauptet dass seinerzeit anlässlich der
deutschen wiedervereinigung
gorbatschow wie versprochen worden sei
dass die nato sich nicht weiter ausdehnt
das ist glaube ich historisch erwiesen
nicht zutreffend zu dem zeitpunkt hatte
niemand daran gedacht danach hat ja dann
auch eine ost erweiterung in mehreren
schüben stattgefunden aber natürlich
sind es sicherheitsanliegen von russland
die nicht völlig illegitim sind
deswegen muss man auf politischen und
diplomatischen
wege dem augen die rechnung tragen und
wenn man jetzt geopolitisch denkt dann
ist natürlich dass sich die situation
von pufferzonen oder neutralisierten
staaten zb zwischen militärischen
blöcken aber diese die ukraine ist ein
souveräner staat die ukraine hat eine
west annäherung versucht die meydan
proteste sind ja gerade dadurch zustande
gekommen dass die bevölkerung ein
assoziationsabkommen mit der eu wollte
und die regierung darauf einen russland
folgen kurs hatte und das nicht wollte
die bevölkerung wollte also
westanbindung sowohl ökonomisch als
auch möglicherweise jetzt militärisch
und das ist die freie entscheidung der
ukraine natürlich darf man nicht naiv
sein und machtverhältnisse außer acht
lassen ja die ukraine so ein kleiner
staat die ukraine hat eine geopolitische
ungünstige lage aber im prinzip darf die
solchen ein beitritt
antrag stellen ob die nato das irgendwie
auf die agenda setzen wird und das
machen würde ist eine ganz andere frage
aber es kann nicht es können nicht zwei
andere staaten ist konnten auch nicht
andere staaten auch nicht im jahr 1990
über die ukraine bestimmen und sagen die
ukraine wird in zukunft niemals einen
beitrittsantrag stellen das geht gar
nicht erst ein vertrag zulasten dritter
ja in der tat also um das vielleicht ein
für alle mal aus dem weg zu räumen weil
das immer wieder ins feld geführt wird
das ist natürlich von geostrategischer
und auch machtpolitischer bedeutung in
dieser hinsicht muss man es natürlich
berücksichtigen aber es spricht
völkerrechtlich einfach überhaupt keine
rolle kann man es so sagen ja vielleicht
kann man man muss natürlich schon darf
man das völkerrecht nicht nur so
aseptisch abgetrennt von den politischen
verhältnissen denn dann wäre das
gerechte wiederum auch nicht wert auf
dem es steht die theorie und anders als
praktisch ist aber nicht so also das
recht selber muss muss den gegebenheiten
auch rechnung tragen aber die
souveränität und damit freiheit von
staatlich ein grundprinzip
geht ja nie wirklich grundlegende
mitbestimmung und selbstorganisation
und nur etwas einem start-up zu sprechen
das ist nicht möglich
real vielleicht gewisse dinge nicht
realisieren kann aber das ist dann eine
sache und kann sich ja auch je nach
situation ändern wir haben es eben schon
gesagt also die ukraine ist kein
mitglied der nato
deswegen lege auch kein sogenannter
bündnisfall vor wenn jetzt putin sich
doch entschließt die ukraine anzugreifen
es hat ja ohnehin auch nur ein einziges
mal eine geschichte der nato einen
solchen bündnis fall gegeben nämlich in
bezug auf die anschläge auf die
vereinigten staaten vom elften september
können andere staaten aber bei springen
wenn sie denn wollen sie haben es eben
schon angedeutet freiwillig kann man so
hilfe eilen oder ja und zwar unter der
überschrift kollektive
selbstverteidigung oder verteidigungs
hilfe artikel 51 der un-charta
berechtigt jeden staates zur
selbstverteidigung wenn ein bewaffneter
angriff droht oder ganz unmittelbar
bevorsteht und zwar individuell und
kollektiv
beispielsweise
haben staaten wie die usa andere und
auch deutschland im jahr 2014 dem irak
militärisch beigestanden als der irak in
einem offiziellen brief an den un
sicherheitsrat und an andere staaten um
hilfe gebeten hat gegen den islamischen
staat
also kollektive selbstverteidigung ist
möglich und erlaubt jetzt würde ich
gerne noch einen blick zurückwerfen auf
das jahr 2014
und was damals geschah damals hat er
russland ja die krim annektiert die
halbinsel die zur ukraine gehört damals
war die sachlage aber eine ganz andere
alles geschah in einer nacht und
nebelaktion deshalb auch wirklich ganz
anders als heute vielleicht um das noch
mal klar zu sagen wie war dieses manöver
damals völkerrechtlich zu bewerten also
die russische föderation hatte aufgrund
von vertraglichen abmachungen eine
gewisse zahl von militär stationiert auf
der krim hat aber dann diese zahl
vertragswidrig erhöht hat dann unter
aufbau dieser militärischen drohkulisse
auf der krim eine volksabstimmung ein
referendum
durchgeführt sehr schnell organisiert
mit nur zwei wochen vorbereitungszeit
und eben vor dieser militärischen
drohkulisse und in dieser
volksabstimmung hat sich dann eine
überwältigende mehrheit für den
anschluss an russland ausgesprochen
dieses referendum war aber aus
völkerrechtlicher sicht
ungültig das hat die un generalverdacht
unter anderem deshalb war er eben gar
keine
weil die internationalen standards nicht
eingehalten wurden zum beispiel man
keine internationalen beobachter
zugelassen das war nicht vernünftig
vorbereitet und das war vor allen dingen
unter militärischer draw
daraufhin hat sich dann die krim auf
diesen auf der basis dieser sozusagen
einen fehlerhaften abstimmung für
unabhängig erklärt und ist dann einen
tag später hat dann die krim ein
beitritt oder eingliederungsvertrag in
die russische föderation geschlossen und
dann sind automatisch alle bewohner der
krim russische staatsbürger geworden die
hat nur einen monat zeit um sich dagegen
auszusprechen und mussten es dann auch
deponieren bei behörden die teilweise
dann auch nicht zugänglich waren viele
hatten dann sicherlich auch angst
deswegen haben wahrscheinlich ich habe
die genauen zahlen vorliegen nur wenige
dann dafür optiert doch ukrainische
staatsbürger zu bleiben aber die un
generalversammlung hat klar gesagt dass
das ungültig ist dass es rechtswidrig
ist dass alle anderen starten das nicht
anerkennen dürfen
der sicherheitsrat hat sich da aber
nicht so geäußert war es auch klar es
war ja russland wie ständiges mitglied
des sicherheitsrats ist und deswegen
sein veto dagegen einlegen wird die
diskussion verlief ihr damals so dass
über das verhalten der volksabstimmung
ein bisschen dem ganzen einen anschein
gegeben werden sollte dass das
völkerrechtlich alles vollkommen in
ordnung ist da gab es diskussionen
darüber auch hier in deutschland die
sind aber inzwischen abgeebbt oder ja
also es ist sowieso
nicht ganz geklärt inwieweit für gebiets
veränderungen zusätzlich eine
volksabstimmung stattfinden muss ich
selber bin sehr großer befürworter weil
ich denke dass das gebiet veränderungen
nicht nur auf dem reißbrett von
großmächten entschieden werden sollen
sondern dass vor allen dingen aus
demokratischen gründen die betroffenen
gefragt werden soll aber wenn hier
gleichzeitig militärische
gewaltanwendung vorliegt dann kann das
sowieso niemals durch eine wie auch
immer geartete volksabstimmung irgendwie
gerechtfertigt
und offensichtlich ist das ein weg dem
jetzt putin zumindest in der ukraine
nicht nochmal so versuchen würde
außerdem würde sie die
mehrheitsbevölkerung also die
bevölkerungen der krim war ja sehr stark
russisch bevölkert was letztlich auch
eine nachwehe noch der sowjetischen
bevölkerungs um siedlungspolitik ist die
ursprünglichen einwohner die krimtataren
die man sowieso schon vorher in alle
winde zerstreut und verschleppt und
umgesiedelt worden hier haben sich dann
zwischendurch auch noch mal zu wort
gemeldet und gesagt dass sie natürlich
sowieso gar nicht damit einverstanden
wären aber davon nur ganz wenige noch
vor ort gucken wir zum schluss noch mal
auf die waffenlieferungen die ja auch
umstritten sind gerade hier in
deutschland natürlich da werden immer
wieder forderungen laut deutschland soll
auch waffen liefern die ukraine wünscht
es sich ausdrücklich aber hier sagt
gerade die ampel koalition immer wieder
nein es gibt eigentlich niemanden der
das lautstark fordert ohne jedenfalls in
diese richtung geht und dann heißt es
immer lieferungen seien rechtlich nicht
möglich
vielleicht klären wir auch das noch mal
stimmt das tatsächlich sind lieferung
von waffen an die ukraine rechtlich gar
nicht möglich
das ist nicht zutreffend
der ausgangspunkt ist dass das deutsche
grundgesetz
angriffskriege verbietet aus der
historischen erfahrung heraus nach dem 2
weltkrieg ist ja das grundgesetz
erlassen worden und in derselben
vorschrift die angriffskriege verbietet
wird auch gesagt dass zur kriegführung
bestimmte waffen nur mit genehmigung der
bundesregierung hergestellte fördert und
in verkehr gebracht werden das nähere
regelt ein bundesgesetz und das
bundesgesetz ist das
kriegswaffenkontrollgesetz
also es gibt relativ strenge
genehmigungspflicht
aber
andererseits haben wir ja eben gesagt
dass
das völkerrecht f der ukraine erlaubt um
hilfe zu bitten um militärische hilfe
zur kollektiven selbstverteidigung
und dass deutschland solche militärische
hilfe zur selbstverteidigung auch
leisten darf und dann kann man sagen
erst recht dürfen auch waffen geliefert
werden deutschland dürfte sogar
militärisch in die ukraine gehen nur zu
verteidigungszwecken natürlich und daher
kommt auch so ein bisschen im diskurs
glaube ich die rede von den defensiv
warten weil es immer im rahmen der
verteidigung sein muss zum zwecke eines
angriffskrieges dürften keine waffen
geliefert werden es gibt allerdings gibt
eine ganz andere diskussion die
eigentlich in der situation hier keine
rolle spielt nämlich die lieferung an
regime die selber ihre eigene
bevölkerung unterdrücken und die waffen
zur internen repression
menschenrechtsverletzungen einsetzen und
so weiter und da gibt es einen
gemeinsamen standpunkt des europäischen
des rates der europäischen union
und es gibt auch einen vertrag im rahmen
der vereinen nationen geschlossen wurde
der arm street und er ist zu weihnachten
2014 in kraft getreten und der sagt er
der sagt klar dass waffen nicht geliebt
der will erstmals illegale die ganzen
illegalen waffen verschiebungen sollen
dadurch geächtet werden und die staaten
die mitgliedstaaten dieses vertrags sei
dazu verpflichtet überhaupt erstmal
kontrollregime einzuführen und so weiter
was er deutschland schon hat und dann
wird gesagt es dürfen keine waffen
geliefert werden wenn der lieferant er
schon weiß dass die waffen dafür
verwendet werden dass schwerste
menschenrechtsverletzungen und schwerste
kriegsverbrechen begangen werden und
wenn die der konkrete verdacht besteht
dass die waffen verwendet werden zu
menschen mit menschenrechtsverletzungen
der einsatz einher geht dann müssen die
stadt das besonders prüfen da sind also
die rechtlichen regelungen und die das
trifft gar nicht die situation um die es
hier geht ja die ukraine will sich nur
vorbereiten gegen einen möglichen
angriff ist kein regime asgard die
waffen benutzt um seine eigene
bevölkerung zu drangsalieren absolut
also rechtlich gibt es da keinerlei
hürden die waffenlieferung im weg stehen
würden aber politisch ist das ganze
natürlich extrem heike extrem umstritten
frau professor peters ich danke sehr
herzlich dass sie uns hier die
völkerrechtliche sicht der dinge
dargestellt haben besten dank jener frau
budras für das gespräch
[Musik]
ja von dem internationalen parkett und
dem völkerrecht kommen wir jetzt wieder
in die niederung der korona maßnahmen
und der politik da kann man jetzt
festhalten dass die lockerungs
diskussions orgien begonnen haben oder
beginnen werden begonnen haben kann man
schon so sagen also die länder haben ja
schon munter 2 gefallen lassen in
vielerlei hinsicht es wird auch in den
kommenden wochen noch mehr werden und
wir werden womöglich tatsächlich am 19
märz dann den einen kleinen freedom day
zumindest haben also das werden wir mal
sehen wie das sich jetzt gestaltet in
den nächsten wochen wir haben hier heute
die bund länder dass bund länder treffen
wieder wo ein fahrplan beschlossen
werden soll aber die dynamik ist er
inzwischen wirklich so schnell dass ich
mich jetzt gar nicht mehr trauen etwas
zu prognostizieren deswegen wollten wir
diesen teil relativ kurz halten und dann
aktuell darauf antworten und das
aufgreifen wenn es denn soweit ist aber
wir haben jetzt noch das
bundesverfassungsgericht zur
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht das
kam letzte woche sehr gut zu pass hat
aber auch so manchen enttäuscht
ja ich glaube es hat vor allem irgendwie
viele ja in den pflegeberufen enttäuscht
natürlich ungeimpfte pflegerinnen und
pfleger hatten sich gegen die
einrichtung bezogene impfpflicht gewährt
aber durchaus auch leiter von
gesundheitsinstituten die eben gesagt
haben wir möchten weiterhin umkämpft das
personal beschäftigen können weil uns
hier sonst der laden zusammenbricht wir
haben ja in der vergangenen woche
relativ ausführlich gesprochen über die
impfpflicht im gesundheitswesen die zum
15 in kraft treten soll und zwar aus dem
grund in der vergangenen woche dass
markus söder und dann auch in der folge
die gesamte cdu gesagt hat irgendwie
finden wir die jetzt die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht jetzt doch doof wir
setzen die erstmal vorläufig auf und aus
und dann kam das
bundesverfassungsgericht mit einem sehr
guten gespür für timing und
hat jetzt entschieden über diese anträge
gegen diese einrichtung bezogene
impfpflicht im gesundheitssektor und hat
sehr deutlich gesagt nein es gibt keine
einstweilige anordnung dieses gesetz
wird in kraft treten wir erinnern uns
gegen gesetze
müsste man eigentlich auch schon immer
sehr grundlegend sehr viel vor bringen
damit das bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt
sagt wir setzen wirklich mein gesetz aus
im wege des einstweiligen rechtsschutzes
in der regel guckt das
bundesverfassungsgericht sich dann an
wie die erfolgsaussichten in der
hauptsache aussehen und demnach
entscheidet das dann so und hier haben
die jetzt gesagt die
verfassungsbeschwerde wäre zwar in der
hauptsache nicht offensichtlich guten
begründet das liegt aber eigentlich gar
nicht an der impfpflicht sondern an
einem formalen fehler da habe ich mich
ehrlich gesagt natürlich ein bisschen
gefreut gucken aber wir haben das ja
jetzt auch schon zwei mal besprochen
zuletzt auch in der vergangenen woche
und zwar das bundesverfassungsgericht
gesagt dass diese doppelte verweisung
mit der im moment gearbeitet wird und
die derzeit dazu führt dass das robert
koch institut und das paul ehrlich
institut über die anforderungen
entscheiden an die geimpften und
genesenen nachweise das ist die wohl
doch für verfassungsrechtlich sehr sehr
zweifelhaft hält das ist natürlich also
wenn man über die frage der impfpflicht
zu entscheiden hat dann geht es
natürlich auch immer darum wer ist denn
eigentlich geimpft in diesem sinne und
das definiert jetzt halt eben durch eine
doppelte verweisung im moment nicht der
gesetzgeber und auch nicht die
bundesregierung per verordnung sondern
das robert koch institut und das
paul-ehrlich-institut
da hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
gesagt das halten wir jetzt als
verfassungsrechtlich doch für sehr sehr
merkwürdig also sie bezweifeln ob es
eine gesetzliche grundlage dafür gibt
dass diese beiden bundesinstitute dann
per webseite bindende regelung mit
außenwirkung schaffen können das ist ja
in etwa das was ich auch jeder normal
denkende mensch dann fragt und außerdem
haben sie auch noch angezweifelt ob der
verordnungsgeber nicht selbst
konkretisieren muss wenn man eigentlich
geimpft und genesen ist jetzt völlig
unabhängig davon ob das vielleicht jetzt
nicht das lka per webseite machen sollte
und das so bild lauterbach jetzt der
tatsächlich wieder ändern genau das hat
er heute morgen der bild zeitung gesagt
das habe ich vorhin auch noch gelesen
hat gesagt er will das wieder irgendwie
an sich ziehen also da ging es glaube
ich um den genesenen status hierbei
bundesverfassungsgerichts geht um den
impfstatus es geht tatsächlich um beides
das ist jetzt immer so ein bisschen
verkürzt dargestellt man ich habe mir
extra die bild heute nochmal vorgeknöpft
also die zitieren jedenfalls aus der
beschlussvorlage für die bund länder
sitzung heute dass er sowohl was die den
genesenen status angeht als auch die
frage wer jetzt als vollständig geimpft
wird wieder selber entscheiden möchte
und da hoffe ich wirklich also die da
ist die erklärung auch so abgefahren
der sagt lauterbach wirklich ein ernstes
also unser gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach sagt er möchte jetzt nicht
mehr
dafür geradestehen für politische
entscheidungen die andere treffen will
sagen also in dem fall in dem
rk ii in sachen genesen status der hier
verkürzt wurde eben von sechs auf drei
monate
und da möchte er nicht mehr gerade
stehen wo man denkt so also ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob sich lothar wieler darum
gerissen hat dieses das selber zu
entscheiden es war ja auch
offensichtlich etwas was aber jedenfalls
der verordnungsgeber schon mal abgegeben
hat wir erinnern uns das war ja
eigentlich tatsächlich mal in eine
verordnung gegossen ja und dann daraus
genommen mit dem ergebnis dass es jetzt
eine doppelte verweisung gibt und jetzt
tut er so ein bisschen so lauterbach als
sei er da opfer geworden eines
einer einer behörde die ihm ja ihr
untersteht ich hoffe das wurde jetzt
echt gesagt alles ein bisschen verkürzt
dargestellt von der bild weil das finde
ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch eine
ziemlich gute begründung also das ding
und das einmal deutlich zu sagen solche
essentiellen sachen müssen von der
regierung und von dem gesetzgeber am
besten geklärt werden ja übrigens auch
nicht nur von herr lauterbach am besten
wäre es dann will ich das in als
verordnung zu machen die entweder von
der bundesregierung oder von den ländern
geschlossen wird oder jedenfalls von
einem gremium das nicht herr wieder ist
und auch nicht der gesundheit minister
karl lauterbach weil das ist einfach zu
wichtig als dass das irgendwie jemand im
alleingang machen könnte um das wirklich
immer genau im alleingang und ohne
hinreichende demokratische legitimierung
das hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
jetzt jedem auch gesagt haben sie so ein
schlenker gemacht irgendwie mit dem man
jetzt mindest nicht zwingend rechnen
musste fand ich aber in der sache hat
das bundesverfassungsgericht auch extrem
deutlich vor allem für ein einstweiliges
ein ordnungsverfahren gesagt dass man in
karlsruhe keine durchgreifenden
verfassungsrechtlichen bedenken gegen
die einrichtung des bezogen der
impfpflicht hat und die abwägung dazu
ist auch wirklich denkbar kurz und knapp
muss man sagen also wie immer vergleich
das bundesverfassungsgericht wie wäre es
denn jetzt wenn wir das gesetz stoppen
und wie wäre es wenn es einfach
weiterläuft und sagt irgendwie naja ohne
impfpflicht gibt halt weniger impfungen
und dann ist das risiko dass sich viele
wohl gerade personen also eben die
patienten und die patienten in den
einrichtungen und deren schutz ist ja
geht bei der einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht mit dem corona virus
infizieren würden bis man dann eben
endgültig über die verfassungsbeschwerde
entschieden hat und das sei sozusagen
schlimmer als das risiko eben das des
personals dass die durch eine impfung in
ihrem körperlichen wohlbefinden
eingeschränkt werden oder aber zunächst
nicht arbeiten können denn das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat auch
relativ kurz und knapp naja was heißt
schon im pflicht die betroffene müssen
sich ja nicht impfen lassen die können
dann halt nicht arbeiten gehen für eine
gewisse zeit
finde ich ist wirklich sehr kurz und
dann kommen so noch ein bisschen die
üblichen argumente naja impfungen haben
wir selten gravierende folgen und die
ist es wichtig dass man die
übertragungskette frühzeitig unterbricht
und das und sagt eben auch noch
impfungen würden halten relevanten
schutz vor infektionen bieten und zwar
achtung auch mit blick auf die omikron
variante des virus also das ist halt
auch schon fast so ein bisschen die der
fingerzeig in richtung allgemeine
impfpflicht wo man sich ja immer gut
vorstellen kann dass nach dem was
bislang so aus aus karlsruhe kommt auch
diese allgemeine impfpflicht problemlos
durchgewunken werden würde wenn sie
nicht vollkommen dämlich formuliert wird
und ich muss sagen dieses diese
entscheidung aus karlsruhe die kann man
jetzt in der sache gut oder schlecht
finden aber ich find sie in der
begründung schon ein bisschen
irritierend denn ist es erstens wirklich
ungewöhnlich dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht sich im
eilverfahren so deutlich positioniert
und es ist ja auch überflüssig denn es
ist ja nur ein eilverfahren im alfa
frank kann man eigentlich sagen na ja
also so die echte rechtsfrage die prüfen
wir normalerweise halt erst in der
hauptsache und stattdessen sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht kann man sich
eigentlich jetzt schon irgendwie
schenken die die hauptsache denn wir
sind jetzt schon davon überzeugt dass
eigentlich die einrichtung bezogene
endlich total in ordnung das aber gar
nicht so richtig du findest sie haben zu
viel gesagt ich wollte gerade sagen das
ist doch eigentlich hätte man sich doch
mehr erwartet oder
nee das sehe ich nicht so also weil
eigentlich müsste das
bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt nur sagen
wir vergleichen wie wäre es denn jetzt
mit impfpflicht und ohne impfpflicht und
dann finden wir es einfach schlimmer wie
es wie es ohne impfpflicht wäre so das
würde ja reichen und das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt aber mal
direkt noch darüber hinaus schließen und
so im übrigen haben wir auch keine
durchgreifenden verfassungsrechtlichen
bedenken gegen die impfpflicht und das
finde ich schon sehr sehr
außergewöhnlich weil damit das ist
eigentlich eine klassische vorwegnahme
der hauptsache und das macht karlsruhe
ansonsten nie na ja nie ist
wahrscheinlich jetzt auch ein bisschen
viel gesagt ich finde
ich hatte jetzt auch nicht gewundert
weil jetzt ja in dieser ganzen pandemie
deutlich geworden ist dass sie nicht der
ausbisse der politik sein wollen und
gerade in dieser konstellation kann man
sich auch vorstellen das ist natürlich
zuallererst eine politische und keine
rechtliche entscheidung ob man so eine
einrichtung bezogene oder auch eine
allgemeine impfpflicht haben möchte aber
ich glaube dass es doch jetzt hier
vielleicht auch eine ganz schöne stelle
um mit der hörer post um die ecke zu
kommen
mach doch mal wer da hab ich muss mal
kurz hier tun denn das freut uns
natürlich immer sehr wenn sie wenn ihr
euch auch zu wort meldet insbesondere
wenn pierre und ich uns ein bisschen zu
einig sind wie es letzte woche ja auch
war vielleicht sage ich an dieser stelle
einfach nochmal die e mail das ist ein
spruch podcast
faz.de da freuen wir uns immer sehr um
durchaus auch abweichende
meinung und hier wurde die geäußert sich
um das nochmal in den kontext zu setzen
pia und ich wir haben hier
letzte woche darüber gesprochen dass
jetzt sehr viel
bedenken rechtliche bedenken geäußert
wurden insbesondere von den bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten markus söder und co
ja dass das alles so vage formuliert sei
und hier zu viele fragen offen seien und
deswegen will söder die nicht vollziehen
diese einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
und friedrich merz cdu chef sagte gleich
sein lassen sonst sie doch aussetzen und
mein petitum war eben einfach ich würde
hier nicht rechtliche dinge vorschieben
rechtliche bedenken vorschieben die
schien mir ein bisschen marginal wenn es
doch eigentlich um schlecht eine
grundsatzfrage geht nämlich wollen wir
die tatsächlich jetzt noch hat sich da
vielleicht was geändert auch am
stimmungsbild in der bevölkerung und vor
allen dingen an der frage wie wir mit
den personalengpässen in der pflege und
im krankenhausbereich umgehen so und da
hat sich tatsächlich einen die leiterin
eines krankenhauses gemeldet die gesagt
hat also bei mir sind zwar 90 prozent
geimpft aber ich sehe trotzdem große
große probleme bei der einführung einer
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht und
zwar sagte sie eben dass sich hier schon
insbesondere seitdem die eingeführt
wurde also im november war ja der
beschluss im die zeit dezember geht
dieses gesetz wissen wir sehr viel mehr
über micon und sie berichtete eben es
dass sich herausstelle dass impfungen
gerade nicht vor ansteckung schützen
tatsächlich erleben wir täglich im
krankenhaus das sich selbst gebastelte
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
anstecken und dass sie andere anstecken
das argument dass man mit der impfung
wohl ne rabl gruppen also die
multimorbiden meist betagten patienten
schützen wolle geht insofern ins leere
es bleibt also nur der schutz vor der
eigenen schweren erkrankung nur wirklich
in anführungsstrichen weil auch das ist
natürlich wichtig bei der beurteilung
dass man sich vor eigene schwere
erkrankungen sehr wohl schützen kann und
dass das natürlich auch zu einer
entlastung des gesundheits
systems führt so und sie hat jetzt auch
das gefühl dass das ganze umschlägt und
sich die beschäftigten in der pflege und
krankenhausbereich jetzt als die
schwarzen schafe empfinden weil sie eben
diejenigen sind also haben sie haben
zwar gebuckelt und alles möglich gemacht
in den letzten zwei jahren aber jetzt
müssen sie eben quasi diese einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht tragen da fühlen
sich viele
kreis hat sage ich jetzt mal meinen
eigenen worten das
eleganter moniert und sie sagt ganz klar
wir können auch auf 10% unsere
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter nicht
verzichten so dann haben wir noch eine
e-mail bekommen von carsten schütz er
ist direktor am sozialgericht in fulda
und der ist noch mal auf die rechtlichen
bedenken eingegangen und
wieder hat mein eindruck widersprochen
dass die durchsetzung einer einrichtungs
bezogenen impfpflicht leicht wäre für
die gesundheitsämter schreibt er ist das
hoch komplex weil sie in jedem fall bei
jeder einrichtung prüfen müssen ob der
schaden des personal ausfalls den sie
mit einem tätigkeitsverbot
herbeiführen schlimmer ist als das
risiko einem nicht g2 menschen mit ft2
maske zu begegnen und er rechne mit
gerichtlichen verfahren mit alpha fahren
die unter zeitdruck laufen und die
arbeitskraft in den landkreisen binden
und er kritisiert auch mal dass es ihm
jetzt ein völlig freies ermessen gibt
dass der gesetzgeber den
gesundheitsämtern eröffnen hat und die
jetzt auch prüfen müssten zum beispiel
ob der lohnausfall für die betroffenen
familien und insbesondere
alleinerziehende
die betroffenen dann in die armut stürzt
so ein vor artikel 3 es ist nicht zu
rechtfertigen jemand seinen beruf zu
untersagen in abhängigkeit vom zufall
wie viele mit ihm ungeübt sind und wie
groß die belegschaft ist so also das
wollte ich hier nochmal als weitere
wortmeldungen ich kenne das auch
wirklich das sind ja auch wichtige
wortmeldungen und die sind ja dinge mit
denen man sich beschäftigen und
auseinandersetzen
meines erachtens bevor man auch als
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt wir haben
dagegen keine durchgreifenden
verfassungsrechtlichen bedenken und das
nur in einem einstweiligen anordnung
verfahren und das ist schlicht nicht
passiert von daher finde ich schon
irgendwie dass man da vielleicht so ein
bisschen ich sage mal nicht verständnis
dafür haben kann aber dass man langsam
nachvollziehen kann das nicht nur bei
gegnerinnen und gegner von corona
maßnahmen der eindruck entstehen kann
dass aus karlsruhe in diesen punkten
echt wenig juristisch ganz tolles kommt
sondern wirklich mehr
ergebnisorientierte entscheidungen die
zum teil wirklich politisch anmuten und
da bin ich jetzt auch wirklich nicht
einer meinung karlsruhe hat da keine
politik zu machen und ich finde das ist
super hier ist möglich schon fast also
weil du jetzt wohin man ist irgendwie
das ist ja irgendwie auch klar dass es
eine politische entscheidung ist und
karlsruhe da nicht rein fischen möchte
und ich finde aber karlsruhe hat schon
juristische entscheidung zu der thematik
zu treffen und um das was von da jetzt
kommt liest sich schon echt fast
politisch muss ich also juristisch
wirklich wirklich schwach und
unbegründet und fast schon politisch und
das noch nicht so im kontext mit dem
timing eben dann in der vergangenen
woche halte sich alle über die über die
einrichtungs bezogenen pflicht stritten
fand ich schon meyer irritierend okay
dass man jetzt mal so stehen und kommen
zu unseren nachträgen
dass du uns etwas zu dem af der richter
jens maier mitgebracht ja da müssen wir
uns jetzt ein bisschen kurz fassen weil
auch da die die sozusagen die geschichte
noch nicht zu ende geschrieben ist hört
euch bitte wenn es euch interessiert die
folge 192 und zwölfter januar an da
hatten wir euch jens mayer vorgestellt
werden jens meyer ist ein ehemals also
ist ein fdp abgeordneter hatte von 2017
bis 2021 mitglied des bundestags war
vorher und wenn es nach ihm geht auch
nachher ist jens maier richter der war
früher am landgericht dresden und er hat
jetzt nach die man nicht eben nicht
wiedergewählt worden ist in den
bundestag hatte einen antrag gestellt
als sächsische justizministerium dass er
in den justizdienst zurück darf und da
gab es dann einen ziemlichen aufstand
weil jens maier selbst für die
verhältnisse der afd ja wie soll man
sagen schon sehr rechtsaußen ist und
weil es berechtigte zweifel daran gibt
dass der mann sich immer so auf dem
boden der freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung bewegt oder sich nicht
vielleicht mehr auf die fahnen
geschrieben hat die zu bekämpfen
jedenfalls hatte das sächsische
justizministerium erst gesagt ja der
mann hat eine rückkehr anspruch und
punkt um wir gucken jetzt nur wo wir den
unterbringen lang gab es aber
tatsächlich zunehmenden öffentlichen
aufruhr und und zunehmend auch auf
widerstand in den medien dagegen und
jetzt hat das justizministerium nach
mehreren wochen
sich bewegt und hat tatsächlich gesagt
okay wir haben jetzt eine entscheidung
getroffen und zwar haben die sich
überlegt jens meyer jetzt in den
ruhestand zu versetzen dass liam lebens
am wochenende der ist gerade 62 geworden
das heißt er hätte jetzt eigentlich
schon noch irgendwie noch knapp vier
jahre so und jetzt seinen ruhestand
versetzt werden das bedeutet natürlich
auch er kriegt dann zwar gekürzt aber er
kriegt weiterhin bezüge kann man sich
jetzt mal pseudo mäßig drei sekunden
darüber aufregen auf der anderen seite
halte ich das erst mal passé eigentlich
für eine vernünftige idee weil da
nämlich die letzten wochen dann so
relativ viel darüber gestritten wurde ob
man den verfehlungen in seiner zeit im
bundestag also wirklich echt entgleisung
wie gesagt hört euch die vorhin
genannten folgen gern noch mal an ob man
die denn sozusagen nehmen kann um jetzt
seinen beamtenstatus zu entziehen oder
in irgendeiner form dafür zu sorgen dass
er eben nicht mehr als richter tätig
werden darf oder ob das nur gestützt
werden dürfte auf äußerungen und so
weiter der als richter getätigt hat und
da hat das justizministerium in sachsen
jetzt offensichtlich versucht einen
anderen weg zu gehen das wird gestützt
auf den ich glaube 31 deutsches richter
gesetz ist das und da sagt das
justizministerium das kann man dann
unter anderem darauf stürzt stürzen
stützen dass jens meyer vom sächsischen
verfassungsschutz als rechtsextrem
eingestuft wird also das heißt dann geht
es vielleicht gar nicht mehr so darum
was hat er denn jetzt eigentlich wann
gesagt und kann man ihm das zu rechnen
ja nein vielleicht und als beamter also
als richter oder als afg abgeordneter im
bundestag sondern man kann sich dann
diese gesamten umstände anschauen die
dazu geführt haben dass er als
rechtsextrem eingestuft wird ob das am
ende so durchgeht dass er dann in den
ruhestand versetzt wird ob er sich
wehren wird und so weiter das weiß man
alles noch nicht das bleibt abzuwarten
aber wir wollten euch zumindest mal den
den sachstand mitbringen dass das
justizministerium sich jetzt nicht mehr
auf den standpunkt stellt ja der hat
halt eine rückkehr anspruch und er kommt
jetzt zurück sondern dass man da jetzt
offensichtlich auch unter hinweis auf
die öffentlichen diskussionen der
letzten wochen die gezeigt hätten dass
das vertrauen der öffentlichkeit in die
sächsische justiz dann massiv
erschüttert werden würde wenn so jemand
hat als als richter zu urteilen hat das
man da sich doch jetzt offensichtlich
bewegen will be posted
und dann sind wir jetzt beim gerechten
urteil du hast uns auch was schönes
mitgebracht bzw das hat uns auch ein
höherer unterbreitete den vorschlag
genau das hat uns das wenn geschick
shoutout ein wirklich sehr hübsches
urteil vom amtsgericht regensburg das
über 50 gramm ziffern langes und echte
komplizierte thematik betrifft aber es
ist wunderschön gerecht wir packen es
euch in die show notes inklusive
aktenzeichen würde ich sagen corinna
denn das könnte vielleicht auch dem
einen oder der anderen als
argumentationshilfe für die zukunft
dienen das amtsgericht regensburg hat
nämlich eine mann-frau transsexuellen
das recht zuerkannt
als vater des kindes in die
geburtsurkunde eingetragen zu werden das
ist eine ehefrau kurz zuvor zur welt
gebracht hatte das klingt jetzt total
schräg einmal ganz kurz im jahr 2020
haben zwei frauen geheiratet
also eine lesbische ehe im november 2000
21 hat eine davon das männliche
geschlecht angenommen also ihr vorname
wurde geändert ist ja es ist jetzt man
geschlechtszugehörigkeit alles nach dem
transsexuellengesetz anerkannt und ein
paar wochen später im dezember 20 21
bringt seine ehefrau ein kind zur welt
und jetzt hat das standesamt sich
gefragt kann der jetzige ehemann der ja
früher eben eine frau war als vater in
die geburtsurkunde eingetragen werden
oder stünde dass paragraph 11 des
transsexuellengesetz entgegen dann hat
es eine kannte ich überhaupt nicht
zweifelsfrei lage gemacht ans
amtsgericht regensburg und das hat
wirklich in einer minutiösen
entscheidung darüber entschieden der
paragraf 11 transsexuellengesetz sagt
die entscheidung dass der antragsteller
als dem anderen geschlecht zugehörig
anzusehen ist lässt das rechtsverhältnis
zwischen dem antragsteller und seinen
kindern unberührt das heißt ich gelte
quasi gegenüber irgendwie der der
gesamten welt als man aber vielleicht
eben nicht mein kind gegenüber es gibt
das dazu wahnsinnig wenig rechts das ag
regensburg hat sich das angeschaut und
sagt selber und wellness rechtsprechung
gibt dann er eigentlich ablehnende also
rechtsprechung die sagen würde der kann
jetzt nicht als vater dieses kindes
eingetragen werden und trotzdem war das
amtsgericht regensburg im ergebnis
diesen mann die vaterschaft zu erkannt
so dass dieses kind jetzt mit zwei
rechtlich anerkannten elternteilen
aufwachsen kann und es ist wirklich ist
es super kompliziert dieses ganze
transsexuellen recht im deutschen
deshalb wahnsinnig kompliziert es ist
auch wahnsinnig irgendwie wie soll man
sagen konservativ und ist seit
ewigkeiten nicht geändert worden ist
auch manchmal nicht stringent ich
versuche jetzt einfach so kurz zu machen
dass man vielleicht einigermaßen
nachvollziehen kann wie das id
regensburg argumentiert die sagen
nämlich vier wänden den elf
transsexuellengesetz gar nicht an denn
der soll das kindeswohl schützen der
sinn von § 11 transsexuellengesetz ist
nämlich das kind soll keine nachteile
dadurch erleiden also familien oder auch
zb erbrechtlich das einst seiner
elternteile seien sein geschlecht und
seine identität verändert
aber welche nachteile können dass sein
weiß man ja dass man zum beispiel dass
man dann zb sein erbe verliert oder so
und jetzt auch das amtsgericht
regensburg dass dieses kind aber gerade
keine nachteile dadurch erfährt dass der
das seien jetzt vater das männliche
geschlecht zugeordnet würde und er quasi
der vater wird im gegenteil sagt das
amtsgericht regensburg das kind hätte
nachteile wenn an das vormals weibliche
geschlecht des jetzigen vaters das recht
kompliziert angeknüpft werden würde denn
und jetzt kommt das ist wirklich lustig
das kind hat ja schon eine biologische
mutter das hat ja das kind auf die welt
gebracht bleibt auch die biologische
mutter die bleibt auch weiblich so und
wenn jetzt aber der frau mann
transsexuelle weiterhin als frau
behandelt werden würde dann hätte das
kind nur ein elternteil weil es nämlich
im deutschen recht keine kur
mutterschaft gibt in lesbischen ehen
denn während man halt wenn man in eine
ehe hineingeboren wird von mann und frau
dann wird man automatisch auch das kind
des mannes obwohl man vielleicht der
vater eben vielleicht nicht der
biologische vater ist
ein ganz ganz deutlich sagen weil im
grunde tut das gericht nichts anderes
als diese sehr pragmatische lösung aus
dem heterosexuellen bereich nämlich zu
sagen also überträgt das denn im
hinteren sexuellen bereich ist es ja
gerade so dass der mann wenn du
verheiratet bist
automatisch der vater wird
selbst wenn ziemlich offensichtlich ist
dass es nicht ist ja also es ist völlig
egal ob das biologisch der vater ist der
wird dann richtig ansehen der vater
sobald das kind in die er hineingeboren
ist also dieses diesen sehr
pragmatischen ansatz aus dem
heterosexuellen beziehung immer trägt er
jetzt auf solchen fall nichts anderes
ist passiert klingt wirklich sehr
pragmatisch und tatsächlich auch für
alle beteiligten absolut sinnvoll
genau also es ist wirklich in im
einzelnen sehr sehr kompliziertes wende
da die vorschrift nicht an und so weiter
aber es begründet das extrem gut mit
sinn und zweck der vorschriften und sagt
na ja am ende irgendwie website eine
krasse ungleichbehandlung gegenüber
kindern die in eine heterosexuelle ehe
hineingeboren werden genau aus diesem
grund weil das eben bei lesbischen
müttern quasi nicht gilt da wird die
eine nicht automatisch mutter wenn die
andere das kind zur welt bringt und dann
sagt das sagt das agi regensburg sehr
sehr schön irgendwie man würde sonst dem
kind die möglichkeit nehmen in der
juristischen sekunde seiner geburt zwei
elternteile zu bekommen die durch einen
form der ehe nach außen deutlich
geworden dass versprechen verbindlich
füreinander einstehen zu wollen
verantwortung füreinander übernommen
haben sie haben vielleicht noch mehr als
heterosexuelle eltern außerdem durch
einen bewussten akt der medizinischen
zeugung des kindes auch dokumentiert
verantwortung für ein kind übernehmen zu
wollen ich finde dem den braucht man
echt nichts hinzuzufügen ja das ist
meine begründung warum das ein gerechtes
urteil ist auch wenn das vielleicht fast
gegen den wortlaut der norm verstößt
aber das ergebnis ist wirklich toll und
wie gesagt wir packen es euch in die in
die shorts vielleicht bringt das dem
einen oder der anderen was als
argumentationshilfe herzlichen dank wie
gesagt für diesen input an sie an euch
ja und bitte mehr davon wie gesagt ein
spruch podcast faz.de ja und dann
verabschieden wir uns für diese woche
warten gespannt auf die beschlüsse der
bund länder sitzung nach her und freuen
uns aufs nächste woche und hoffen dass
ihr uns bis dahin gewogen bleibt habt
eine gute woche
[Musik]